c'est les 24 heures télé 24 mai 48 ont
ressenti les 24 tentés qu'il fallait pas
rater à la télé heure par heure ces
dernières 24 heures c'est une séquence
sans but n pour ceux qui sont imposés en
effet comique et yeux fermer les yeux
djokovic ses parts sur tf1 on a croisé
quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup dans un
train corail
c'est kyan khojandi de brefs dans un
instant gros poids sur le retour de koh
lanta sur tf1 et chez les waka et
l'ambiance était ouf
mais pourquoi sont ils aussi content on
a la réponse chez de matthieu delormeau
et c'est historique
matthieu delormeau
[Applaudissements]
vous arrivez à la voir c'est waou temps
les anges thomas lui d'un petit soucis
il n'a pas la bonne notion du temps toto
il aux aubrais faire une pause 200 sur
canal on parle beaucoup de la bagarre de
femmes il ya eu des vrais moments
d'amour aussi prochain ouais c'est ça
aussi le foot via la belle avec sa voix
et carnet rose deux anciens chroniqueurs
et nora qui nous manque en loge et
gérard louvin avec son jeune enfant de
stars ensemble une fille on l'a vu dans
midi en france
mais epinal aussi grâce à vous et
l'oratorio doute qu à tous les soirs
invités très prochainement et web et
bellouët chassons bim
volta est chez combal la bonne humeur
nos téléspectateurs a toujours été une
priorité pour à quatre meilleurs une
personne qui a perdu du poids grâce à
leurs produits c'est pas nourri jours
donc ça hyper en a lui même sont en alu
ce qui se passe donc ils font répéter
300 fois le poids combien vous avez
perdu grâce j'ai perdu 6 kilos laurence
vous avez perdu combien de kilos j'ai
perdu 6 kg et dans ce cas le kilo alors
je me suis ses kilos et vous combien de
kilos ce mois-ci kg lolo laurent guyot 6
kg est toujours utile dans cet abri ont
raté expression une justice à deux
vitesses arrive aux meilleurs
mais qu'on aille au bout des choses
pourquoi est ce que on a l'impression
d'avoir une vitesse a de justesse un
médecin de mac de la santé parlant du
mag a compris trop tard qu'il allait
vraiment un petit peu trop loin dans
l'anatomie équipe on chez d'état ça et
ça reprend un vieux mythe mais du
moyen-âge qui s'appelle levage in adult
à tester dès qu'il y avait des vagins
avec des dents à l'intérieur qui mordait
le sexe de l'homme lorsque le vagin ne
vous plaît pas par par quelqu'un
d'extérieur
bref
pendant ce temps là sur arte ils ont eux
aussi lancé leur propre version des
power rangers ça fait plaisir arte
[Musique]
obama
on a bien regardé on passe au jt ouais
on va passer au jt une image un petit
peu hallucinant que dans les jt ces
entités de tf1 ils ont interviewé
l'avocat de laetitia ali et mesut vide
et ouais c'est très chaud nous et
perturbant il a la même vote notre
ancien président jacques chirac l'avocat
mais à tel point nous dire in fine
vannes à la télé au gré des films comme
donc ne rigole un pote mais non c'est sa
voix exprime la quiétude de sa cliente
laeticia hallyday est très sereine c'est
qu'elle a le droit et la loi pour elle
laeticia hallyday est très seul parce
qu'elle sait qu'il a le droit et la loi
pourrait sur bfm céline pitelet c'est
gratos et a du mal avec le nom du
président sncf où est le patron de la
sncf guillaume pepy a dit et si caron a
promis sinon la rédac de tf1 ça bouge à
il envoie toujours des journalistes
courir les intempéries en fonction de
leur nom de famille des dizaines des
centaines d'euros sur une autre
manifestation sous la pluie aussi à
saint-etienne jean marie deleau et david
on a même enregistré les plus grosses
chutes de neige de l'hiver
philippe au gel et reaching se regarde
sur france ô il va même encore plus loin
ils ont fait un reportage sur une île où
il ya une seule famille apparemment une
situation qui pourrait affecter tout le
réseau documentaire calédonien selon les
agents en écoute karine pour aegon au
micro de marguerite poids ghosn
[Musique]
la soutiennent j'aurais pu rien faire
mais j'ai regardé les enfants de la télé
sur france 2 avant il ya débat sera
capable ici
benji exactement on a croisé n'y avait
pas que benji laurent ruquier tout ça et
on a vu une star également en discret
dans le public
regardez le flou combat stories est bien
sortie de jean pierre foucault laurent
ruquier recevait le chanteur guerre fort
et galfond et les caches n'aime pas pour
le coup de gueule la télévision c'est la
folie on vient une star de manière très
rapide une star éphémère en plus mais ce
que je peux vous poser une question non
et après
[Musique]
c'est ma préférée sur tf1 sera the boys
à pascal obispo il a été très ému il
arrive même plus à expliquer ces
sentiments et soigné quoi s'écoute pas
soit il est vraiment écrit et puis betty
le truc c'est que moi j'appelle ça
l'inexplicable je peux pas vous
expliquer expliquez-nous la tête de
négoce explique que nous n'en avons pas
lui parler ou même si j'adore ça
l'inexplicable je peux pas vous
expliquer expliquer d'où l'effort et
vendredi j'ai regardé landes tacot c'est
que l'on tend vers le web
chaouch de la nouvelle saison 6 mois
callas font ils ont une nouveauté c'est
l'exil serait lente et éliminé en début
d'aventuré finalement personne s'y
attend et tu reviens un peu comme
bernard montiel dont tpp
je suis dans la voiture avec dylan
notamment on peut pas à ce point foot à
pamiers dans la gueule de quelqu'un par
inadvertance des palmes pour le toit
quand même pas qu'on attende clémentine
a réussi l'exploit de sortir la phrase
la plus classe du jeu depuis la première
saison en 2001 enfin un débrief dans
l'eau ouais à l'événement vous arrive
la classe à dallas elle est pas non plus
hyper calé sur l'eau on va pas se mentir
c'est assez rare donc là on a vu un beau
la beauce sait pas trop si c'est de
l'eau salée de l'eau sucrée ou salée
pendant l'émission on a remarqué que
julie est une grande fan de claude
françois
merci
[Applaudissements]
et alors petit cadeau pour cheryl on
s'est demandé ce que ça donnait sur
mettez la voix de patrick montel et ses
pronostics sur eux sur des épreuves de
kolontar product attention à lui
attention à lui qu l'olt polonais
pourrait bien continuer à mon avis va
aller très loin kouba qui avait porté la
poisse entier en l'air mais samassa pas
de vent oui je pense qu'elle espérait un
peu mieux quand même à néo zélandaise ma
carte est allé passer à 70 c'est que
même le blasé bons coups bas qui
combattirent qui remonte à quelques cd
cd comme tu pu les entendre cucchi
ousseynou la spontanéité du javelot
saison mais faire c'est sûr
c'est comme ces aux jo-2000 t'as pas
remarqué tu regardes n'importe quel
sport mondial ya des chances de
médailles au tir à l'arc à 20 mètres un
bâti tchèque ou baptisé je vais le
garder on embrasse les frères karabatic
et pour gagner la coupe de france et
l'étoile a un ça va ce aussi à tous les
gens qui sauvait envie de partir 30 dans
le bourg du rationnel ouais c'est le
money time comme 10 des espagnols c'est
bientôt la fin du mois 45 chapeau qui va
passer dans le public si vous posez une
attaque avait fait pour l'équipe
j'ai regardé hui chance de tout gagner
pour vous gagnez une chance de tout
c'est mieux si je veux toi tu aimes bien
belle j'ai dit je trouve des extraits
pour et j'aime tous les jeux mois
souvent aux chaudes à ce genre salut du
monde alors est une candidate qui est
mère au foyer
mais c'est pas ce qui nous a choqués
c'est plus les fistons de la maman qui
au foyer services de marketing
opérationnel et vous sylvie maman à la
maison
combien enfants deux garçons le 30 ans
et 32 ans
qu'attend badens la nyanga qui s'est
confiée à cyril féraud sur ses activités
sportives beaucoup de voyages en fait un
mode sport pour garder la forme
je fais quelques sports extrêmes autres
attentions alors c'est quoi du ski
freestyle du parachutiste du saut à
l'élastique du v jump scrabble quelques
sports extrêmes la pétanque et la danse
country
et puis tiens j'ai une pensée pour ce
lait qui s'est fait piquer par un cactus
ont randonné c'est pas une blague
il souffre énormément donc un pote gay
s'est lui retiré le cactus de la jambe
c'est hyper double
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça y est les chiffres de l'autre côté
quoi on a le temps on a un dernier truc
vous savez non non vous le savez notre
ancien camarade capucine a récemment
sorti une autobiographie qu'elle a
présentée au salon du livre dont cia
peut-être un filon à faire il est un
petit peu de pesos à se faire arrêter au
salon du livre
oui ouais juste salon du livre mais à
tout élément y avait du monde
bien sûr et donc nous on aime on s'est
dit pourquoi on n'en serait pas un autre
livre
on est allé faire croire aux gens dans
la rue que cyril hanouna sortait sa
biographie sobrement intitulé pour une
poignée de dinars positon pas marion
devrait donc présenter ce faux livres
avec des fausses phrase est issu du
livre il n'a publié livres ou quoi des
phrases qui pourrait être dans une
biographie de syrie rien n'est vrai on
les a inventés faut demander aux
passants de nous les lire et donner
leurs réactions sur ces passages inventé
dès qu on n'est pas loin du goncourt
on est donc marcher avec le livre sous
la main on a croisé peu de monde y est
même richard gotainer qu'on a croisé par
hasard ça fait plaisir
et voici les réactions des passants
face à la plume anuncio
c'est ouf molière sur la tête d'un chat
errant le kiff de ouf c'est rodez d'arc
à ce gars à bio connaît les joueuses le
gard la plus grande réussite c'est quand
j'ai réalisé une chenille géante à
l'intérieur de l'assemblée nationale
ça fait pas très sérieux aussi d'axa à
dire c'est pas de gaulle
j'ai fait des essais pour présenter le
jt de 20h mais je me suis fait éjecter
parce que je pensais que trinidad et
tobago c'était un groupe de zouk
bon ben je crois que je vais pas plus
loin quand j'arrive chez ces huit
j'utilise mon zizi pour choisir les
tâches puis mon zizi pourquoi mon café
qui ont saisi pour le tout y est je
compte j'ai les mains propres toute la
journée l'hygiène c'est très important
écoutez son zizi bas ils gardent bien au
chaud et ça nous intéresse pas j'ai
toujours voulu faire du cinéma je viens
terminé le scénario de mon premier fils
touche pas mes boules à istanbul mais
vole à istanbul nous montre tout ça
c'est pas il ne le dit mais vous verrez
pied
[Musique]
alors vive le voir car il sait que c'est
fait avec panier dinosaures ils sont sa
passion c'est un à boire et non plus un
c'est qu'ils sont persuadés que c'est
votre bellegarde
je le garde oh merci merci merci des
amis avec la nuque ont valu au nouveau
boss la vie sauvage les jurés